spaghetti gate uh I think it happened
when I was actually hanging out there's
like 10 years ago there was an Italian
restaurant that had a menu that said
spaghetti on it and the language police
said where's the French and they were
like what and they're like it says
Spaghetti where's the French and they're
like what it's spaghetti and they got
fined for not writing spaghetti
prominently in French and having the
Italian words
I need to remember the exact name of it
there's a story why Tim Hortons doesn't
have an apostrophe s all right and it
goes back to this I think it was called
Sam's garage but I might be mistaken on
the name it doesn't matter all the
matters is there's an apostrophe in
there there's no apostrophes in French
so they said Sam's garage that's not
French uh there was an exception for
registered trademarks they said that's
not French they said well well I'm gonna
put a a Canadian flag over the
apostrophe now it's Sam's without it
without it it's French Tim Hortons
didn't want to have to have two
brandings they didn't want to have Tim
Horton's apostrophe s for the rest of
Canada so they just go Tim Hortons
without a nest yeah that's the Sonic